[Music]
this is the state's case against Gypsy
Rose Blanchard
she's got paraplegic epilepsy heart
murmur and she's allergic to sugar
everything I do I do for her
my mom is impossible all she wants to do
is Kinsey Jeff Wright have you been able
to confirm the girl's medical history
which part any of it this what being a
mom is never being sure you're doing the
right thing but doing it anyway not with
the children's division of Missouri
social services go big ships he's got
the mind of a second now what are you oh
she's 15 form in 1995 I think you said I
was born in 1993 I'm just gonna ask you
a few questions all right can you read
[Music]
- you love me buddy you giggling about I
never leave Prince Charming I never once
disrespected my mama the way you do I
can't tell anyone you can tell me
nobody's gonna ever do more for you
she's never gonna let us be together
sooner or later everybody knows
everything about everyone
[Music]
Gypsy Rose Blanchard how do you plead
[Music]
you